nothing exceptional takes little time if
it were easy then it means it's low
hanging fruit if it's low hanging fruit
other people have already done it it's
the high fruit that take the latter that
take the climbing that take getting cut
by leaves and whatever that's still
there for the picking most of the big
wins in life come from the hard to
attain fruit and the key to most of
those treasure chests is actually right
in front of most people there's just a
Time clock on the treasure chest the
key's sitting on top of it and says wait
five years and then you can unlock it
it's in plain sight it's not a secret
it's just the thing that makes it hard
is not the complexity it's the
consistency